april 2nd 2020 it's only been a month
since kovid was officially declared a
pandemic the first case of the deadly
chinese coronavirus making its way to
the u.s everything is still pretty fresh
around the world everyone is quarantined
in their homes
and the mckean family is no different
maeve and david mckeen are quarantining
with their three kids gabriella toby and
gideon
they're staying comfortable in a house
in the chesapeake bay the family figures
it's the perfect place to hunker down
and wait for the pandemic to subside the
house was out in the country so the kids
would have plenty of room to run around
and play
on the afternoon of april 2nd one of the
kids gideon is playing kickball outside
with his mom maeve
during the game the kickball gets kicked
a little bit too far and ends up in a
nearby cove so maeve and gideon decide
to hop in a canoe to retrieve the ball
from the water they're paddling out onto
the water when they're swept up by the
tides or maybe the wind and pushed out
into the deadly open bay they drift
helplessly out into three foot waves and
29 mile per hour winds 30 minutes later
a random onlooker sees the mom and child
aimlessly floating in the waves he calls
the police at around 4 30 hopeful that
help will arrive in time
but that would be the last time maeve
and her son gideon would ever be seen
alive again
6 30 rolls around darkness is just
around the corner the coast guard
recovers the canoe but maeve and gideon
are nowhere to be found
the canoe was capsized and miles away
from where they were last seen
a day later the husband and father broke
the news over facebook to his friends
and family they had been out there in
the bay without a boat for nearly 24
hours now and another night was
approaching fast
maeve and getting were almost surely
dead four days later mae's body was
found dead after another two days
eight-year-old gideon was discovered two
thousand feet from the body of his
mother
on behalf of the people of maryland i
expressed our most heartfelt sympathies
and prayers
to her
and to her entire family
the story of maeve and gideon is tragic
you could chalk it up to being in the
wrong place at the wrong time or a bit
of bad luck that terrible things just
happen to good people sometimes but if
you take a look at their family tree a
startling picture starts to emerge
you see mae's mother's maiden name was
kennedy
and mae's grandfather was a man named
robert f kennedy yes that kennedy the
brother of the former president john f
kennedy and what you have to understand
about the kennedy dynasty is that
although they are very powerful the
kennedy family has been riddled with
unfortunate death after unfortunate
death generations of kennedy's dying too
soon under suspicious circumstances so
much that there's a name for this
backstring of luck
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team and this is a story
of the rise of one of the most powerful
families in american history and the
unfortunate deaths that haunted them
this is the kennedy curse
the kennedy family is known for two big
things their curse and their success but
they weren't just handed their success
the kennedys built their legacy on
skills skills that would take them to
the top of the business and political
worlds things like public speaking
negotiation productivity and if you want
to move up in life you're gonna need
some of those skills too that is where
skillshare comes in skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of courses that give you the chance to
explore your passions let's be real the
people who make a lot of money are the
ones with the best skills and skillshare
can help you learn the skills you need
on demand no matter what topics you're
interested in you'll find it on
skillshare there are just so many unique
courses and many of them can help you
become a better business person and make
more money like youtube success scripts
shoot and edit by none other than the
tech giant youtuber marquez brownlee
there's also stock market fundamentals
and social media for creatives to start
off i'd recommend the youtube course i
mentioned above because marquez is an
absolute beast to learn from there are
tons of experts teaching on skillshare
right now skillshare is constantly
putting out new and interesting courses
and you'll never be distracted by ads or
interruptions during your class the
entire course catalog is also now
available with subtitles and spanish
french portuguese and german the first 1
000 people to use the link
skillshare.com jake or my code jake tran
will get a one month free trial of
skillshare that skillshare.com with the
link below to start learning on
skillshare today thanks to skillshare
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Music]
rosemary kennedy was born in 1918 the
eldest daughter of nine kennedy siblings
and the little sister to the future
president john f kennedy rosemary was
thought to have suffered from a lack of
oxygen at birth the family always said
that she was a little slow in her 20s
rosemary started becoming irritable and
acting out more she would have mood
swings and throw fits it was a complete
embarrassment for the head of the family
joseph kennedy's senior who was trying
to keep rosemary struggle a secret
if he wanted his sons to rise to the top
of the political ranks his family needed
to look picture-perfect so in 1941 her
father decided to put rosemary through
an experimental new procedure a lobotomy
a treatment that involved putting a
sharp ice pick looking tool into the
frontal lobes of the brain through the
eyeball and wiggling it around
yeah rather disturbing her dad had her
go through this without consent and
didn't tell the rest of the family until
after it was already done in big shocker
the procedure was totally botched the
lobotomy left rosemary with the brain of
a two-year-old she couldn't walk or talk
for the rest of her life to keep her out
of the public eye rosemary was locked up
in private institutions for the rest of
her life 86 years until she died in
2005.
although rosemary didn't die right away
she marked the beginning of many more
deaths to come
[Music]
joseph kennedy jr was rosemary's oldest
brother and had been preparing for a
bright political career when he was born
his father picked him up and proudly
said this child is the future president
of the nation
joseph had plans to attend harvard law
school but he volunteered to pilot a
top-secret secret bombing mission during
world war ii and in 1944 an explosive on
his plane blew up early it completely
destroyed the plane killing joseph jr
and his co-pilot instantly
he was 29 years old only four years
after mourning the loss of their first
child rose and joseph kennedy senior
would be grazed by death again
kathleen was the fourth of the kennedy
children she was lovably known as kik
for her outgoing personality two years
after her husband died kick started an
affair with a man her dad didn't approve
of a married man to be specific
she decided to visit her father in paris
to convince him that her new boyfriend
was the real deal when they stopped
their 10-seat plane to refuel near paris
the pilot warned them that the poor
weather made it unsafe to take off but
kik's boyfriend insisted that they get
back up in the air can you guess the
rest of the story
yep the plane crashed
kik her boyfriend and the pilot all died
on impact
her father was the one who identified
kick's body by the 1950s the kennedys
had lost three of their nine children in
one way or another but it was only the
beginning of the family's curse
[Music]
[Music]
with joseph senior's eldest son dead he
turns his attention toward his second
eldest son john f kennedy in this time
the kid actually lived long enough to
reach his dad's political expectations
jfk would be sworn in as the 35th
president of the united states
hi john fitzgerald kennedy do you
solemnly swear that you will faithfully
execute the office of president of the
united states and i will faithfully
execute the office of president of the
united states so help you god so help me
god
by the 1960s everyone knew the kennedy
name and people loved jfk his approval
rating was higher than almost any other
president in american history it seemed
like things were finally turning around
for the kennedy family until 1963. in
august jfk's wife jackie kennedy gave
birth to a premature baby boy they named
him patrick and rushed him to be
baptized patrick only lived 39 hours
before dying of something called hyaline
membrane disease the couple was
completely devastated they had already
suffered one miscarriage and a
stillbirth before patrick but even in
grief jfk had to continue his political
campaign the next presidential election
was coming up quickly and that's when it
happened
here is a bulletin from cbs news
in dallas texas three shots were fired
at president kennedy's motorcade in
downtown dallas the first reports say
that president kennedy has been
seriously wounded by this shooting
november 22nd 1963
dealey plaza in dallas texas john f
kennedy becomes the fourth u.s president
to be assassinated it would go down as
one of the most infamous and
controversial assassinations in history
forever solidifying the kennedy curse
but john wouldn't be the last victim of
the curse in the 1960s
[Music]
this is robert f kennedy aka bobby
kennedy jfk's younger brother bobby was
moving up the ranks of the democratic
party he was a top choice for the
democratic presidential nomination and
he was hoping to fill the shoes jfk left
on a summer night in 1968 bobby was
celebrating he had just won the
california primary and things were
looking good for the presidency
bobby had just finished up a victory
speech at the ambassador hotel in
california
i thank all of you who made this
possible this evening all of the effort
that you made and all of the people
whose names i haven't mentioned and
that's when it happened
bobby kennedy was shot multiple times by
a young palestinian man
the killer claims to have acted in
retaliation against rfk for his
pro-israelite stance bobby kennedy died
in hospital the next day it would become
yet another hotly contested
assassination
by now four kennedy siblings were dead
and the curse was about to get someone
who wasn't even a kennedy the youngest
kennedy ted had narrowly escaped death
in 1964. he survived a plane crash that
killed two other people and got out of
it with a broken back and ribs
after making a recovery from the crash
ted went back to his political career he
was a super successful senator from
massachusetts in the summer of 69 ted
was driving his oldsmobile home from a
party on chappaquiddick island just
after 11 pm
28 year old mary jo kopechny was with
him after taking a sharp turn he missed
the ramp onto a narrow wooden bridge and
the car plunged into a big pond
ted managed to escape the sinking car
but when he got to safety he didn't call
the police or an ambulance for mary jo
he left the scene returned to his hotel
and went to sleep
it wasn't until 10 hours later that he
finally decided to call the police by
then they had already recovered mary
jo's dead body from the water the whole
ordeal became known as the
chappaquiddick incident and it
absolutely destroyed the political
career of the youngest kennedy after
that the curse would settle down for a
little while all the way up until the
1980s
[Music]
david kennedy was the son of bobby
kennedy the second kennedy that was
assassinated david was only 13 years old
when he watched his dad get killed after
getting hit with such intense trauma
david turned to heroin and alcohol to
cope after a lifetime of struggling with
addiction he died of an overdose in
1984.
david was found dead in a palm beach
hotel room cocaine a painkiller and a
mood disorder medication were found in
his body it seemed like the curse was
coming back to clean the next generation
of kennedys
1997 michael kennedy another son of
roberts is skiing in aspen colorado with
his family it's new year's eve and
they're all tossing around a football
while riding on an expert slope the game
was a kennedy family favorite while
playing michael ran into a tree at 4 15
pm the ski patrol arrived within four
minutes and started administering first
aid but it was too late
at 5 50 michael kennedy was pronounced
dead
only two years later the curse strikes
again big time
john f kennedy jr the famed president's
only living son took off from essex
county airport in new jersey he was
flying a single-engine plane with his
wife and sister-in-law he only had about
300 hours of flying experience but told
his flight instructor he wanted to do it
alone anyways their destination was
martha's vineyard about 200 miles away
over the very dark and expansive
atlantic ocean
these conditions can mess up even
experienced pilots and that's when jfk
junior got confused the plane fell from
over 2000 feet to 1000 feet in 14
seconds before disappearing completely
it took five days to find the bodies of
jfk jr and his passengers the untimely
death of jfk's only son shocked the
nation but those following the bloodline
know that it was just another death from
the kennedy curse
let me say that
john kennedy and his sister and later
his wife were uncommonly kind
to my daughter and to my wife and
this has been a very difficult thing for
us personally as well as
because of my position
they are very strong people
and
i think they're carrying on as well as
any human beings could
but they need the support and prayers of
our country
[Music]
the kennedys prayed that the curse had
ended with the turn of the century for
around 10 years there weren't any deaths
or accidents but then it came back with
a vengeance
2011
kara kennedy the daughter of ted kennedy
is working out at a health club in
washington dc when she suddenly dies of
a heart attack
cara was only 51 it was super unexpected
because she was in such good health
2018
christopher kennedy lawford jfk's nephew
dies of a heart attack at age 63. the
actor and writer's death was also
completely unexpected
2019
the curse starts making its moves on the
newest generation of kennedys
at 2 30 pm first responders are called
to an emergency at the kennedy family's
compound in massachusetts they're
rushing to help cersei roasts and
kennedy the granddaughter of bobby
kennedy after an accidental overdose but
they don't make it in time
at 3 14 pm sercia is pronounced dead at
the cape cod hospital she had methadone
diazepam ethanol and three other
prescription drugs in her system when
she died tragedy at the kennedy compound
a grief stricken family reeling
sercia kennedy hill the 22 year old
granddaughter of ethel kennedy and the
late senator robert kennedy confirmed
dead late thursday
her death came after a long struggle
with depression a struggle she depicted
in a school essay saying although i was
mostly a happy child i suffered bouts of
deep sadness that felt like a heavy
boulder on my chest
less than a year later came the deaths
of maeve and gideon kennedy mckean in
chesapeake bay
from the outside the kennedy name is
synonymous with wealth influence and
power that anyone would be envious of
but on the inside it's a bloodline
filled with endless suffering
[Music]
and if you want to get a free stock yes
a free stock with anywhere from three to
a thousand dollars all you have to do is
go to public.comtrend and create an
account public is a social stock trading
app that is a serious game changer
because you can follow other investors
right in the app to learn what they
invest in giving you a huge competitive
advantage so go to public.com to get a
free stock with the link below thanks
the public for sponsoring this video
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you're new here my name is jake and we
make documentaries just like this one
every single week on money power and
crime multiple times a week for free so
if you enjoyed this one click the
subscribe button below remember you can
always dislike and unsubscribe whenever
you want so you have nothing to lose and
everything to gain if you want longer
documentaries that are too controversial
to post publicly click that join button
below we just put out a documentary on
the bin laden papers that was seized
during the raid that killed bin laden
super fascinating video that would
definitely get them monetized because it
talks about bin laden and 911 all the
things youtube doesn't like and you can
watch it right now by clicking that join
button below there's a refund policy too
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it just email me and i'll
personally refund you the money no
problem you can follow me on instagram
jaytrain.io that's gonna wrap it up
thank you so much for watching stay
dangerous out there and i'll see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you